have that deeper connection with someone
so but they can't because they've slept
with too many people so I don't I think
it's like um I don't think it's wrong
girls want to be with like the best that
they can do basically and so I'm
definitely punching
and and so the the thing is like the
more men that a woman slept with the
less likely he is the best that she can
do but but like look at I mean there's
times where like and and then it's like
she can't do as well because you know
he'll find out about three guys she
slept with
I feel like I have not wife in that one
I'm good it's true but that that's what
I think it is I think that the standards
get higher and I don't think that's
necessarily a bad thing but obviously
when this awkward situation now where
like you know that that competition is
getting a bit unreachable for most dudes
um but yeah but I I do think like this
conversation is weird because it's both
like spiritual and like reality so in
reality the fact is we have those
objective levels right like you know
there are objective standards between
what you what a man is willing to invest
in for a long-term relationship on the
other side you should be able to kind of
Express Yourself freely and not not be
judged in that way because I don't think
every time someone sleeps around us
necessarily because they're there so you
need to kind of have some traditional
conservative opinion on oh she's this or
that I know a lot of women who can have
casual relationships and they know the
boundaries and I know a lot of people
who tell themselves they can have cash
relationships with actually looking for
something deeper and there's women who
are doing that but they're actually
damaged there's women who are kind of
virgins but they're deeply traumatized
you know it's not the world isn't that
simple I think that Nuance needs to be
there of like I agree so slapping things
on people you're right bro but how do we
create a filter to find out who's who
you get to know let me tell you how
because the world has done it for time
every with anywhere else in our lives
other than relationships everybody
follows the same rules credit score as
soon as you go to get a loan what's the
first thing they do they look at your
history when you go to get a job what's
the first thing you look at your history
when you get arrested and you make a
crime what's the first thing they look
at so how do you find their history
handles how do you have that yeah yeah
nowadays it's on your social media it's
everywhere
that's the problem like I think that one
of the best indexes I think one of the
best Industries like I think I think one
of the ways I think one of the best
Industries going forward is going to be
um erasing women's sexual Past online I
think that's gonna be like you want to
be rich that thirst traps you were
probably like
um there's traps you were posting when
you're 18 it's it it's a shame for you
in a way because you're paid to do it
but it's like I could see how that would
no like there's definitely times where
like I definitely don't do anything
extreme now it's more like well actually
I'm like quite invested in someone at
the minute so I'm not talking to any
guys but
um
is some things I have posted and I know
they're going to come back to like bite
me in the ass one day and I do really
regret that so yeah I can see what
you're saying yeah and I think people
would pay thousands of dollars to get
some of that [__] that you twerking I've
literally been sent like 2K from one guy
just for conversing and like talking and
like talking I was like I'll have an
insecure about my nose he was like oh
let me send you the money for it and I
didn't send any news or like yeah it's
crazy you know
um okay you go and then go ahead can I
just say this may sound a little bit
barbaric but I say this to all my
friends and they hate me for it he's
probably gonna tell me off later but
like I feel like
um there is certain like some people are
just better than others like you can
just some people will just you know
whether that's looks or the decisions
they make and it doesn't mean that every
girl that has slept with you know loads
and loads of guys is traumatized or hurt
or you know she's trying to to forget
something sometimes it just means that
she makes really bad decisions and I
mean still a holder exactly
this is so stressful because what these
what these like I'm sorry baby you know
I love this respect for hours
it does work tell us would you describe
it yeah you gotta use the word the word
scribes
I'll just say she gets around I don't
know I've I've come she does a tank I
kind of reached this point of like
avoiding being unnecessarily
disrespectful so so for me and I think
this happens a lot in this space of like
people get so obsessed with this
conservative Viewpoint of having to
judge people and I think people get a
kick out of being like you slept with
three people four years ago so you are
bam or if you don't do this then you
aren't good enough for these standards
XYZ and I get that I'm that is not wrong
at all but I think
eventually and I had a bad hinge there I
learned this like yesterday
yeah well I went off now about like we
were talking and then she was obviously
a feminist and then we had that feminist
conversation and she just first date I
did I filtered
okay if you if you have any of those
like you know those like all men are
stupid oh my God my brother's dumb
because he wants to be in finance he's
supporting the patriarchy I was like all
right so your family so what would you
say if people thought you were like an
[__] that kind of conversation yeah
um and I can afford to do that but
essentially I got kind of reverse
traumatized because she basically didn't
say anything and she was very
intelligent one to the top uni in London
and I kind of realized that traumatized
me I was like well she she really didn't
talk she didn't like normally they you
know the delusions come out and it's
like this that and I kind of realized
that was just unnecessarily mean I guess
like you know even if she didn't meet
any standards or she had any silly ideas
about being you know sexually liberated
or having people she slept with you
didn't I didn't really need to do that
like you know I could have seen the best
in her and assumed she was decent person
he wants a meaningful relationship with
I think 99 of people are but instead I
went with the red pool stuff and you
know it you know so so that's why I'm on
this like do we have to call each other
hoes could you just be like that
learn better language there's a
difference she going up to a random girl
you don't know and calling her a hoe and
describing
yeah obviously in person obviously in
person but sometimes even in a group
dynamic like I think I think we all know
what that is without having to be like
because we all know who is a derogative
it's not respectful terms that's that's
why you wouldn't say it to someone in
person but I'm just saying like we never
have this conversation about like simps
so it's like if I I don't think it's
derogatory to call man a Sim no it's not
and I would do it I don't think I think
it is I think it is that's terrible
that's you like that's you this like
burning like putting your finger in the
skull but it's like if you call a man a
simp he might stop simping
yeah
no I think sometimes like that's how a
lot of guys in the red pill space get
started
yeah most guys I think I think most guys
have been taken advantage of by a girl
they were simping for at some time
absolutely I can name my hundreds yeah I
know I know I know I know I know a list
of people that are simping as hard as
they possibly can oh yeah I know a lot
of my sisters
together and say you know hey stop
simping you're simping same thing with
girls like if you start getting called a
hoe you might do it less but not really
do what you want more of a like a it has
a more of a permanent kind of stamp like
no I would say [__] or something
yeah but you know what we all know that
if you call someone
you've changed
but then you come in and the first thing
you said like
that's a fun time fun time I do I
wouldn't allow them um
and I thought my daughter's 18 and
there's no way I would be like Oh yay
you're a hoe because it's fun you might
not hear it but she's probably doing no
she's what how about having sex she's
having no no not that and I don't mean
that I mean just like okay
I remember though you know she's not but
it's like I wouldn't as a mother to a
girl be like oh this is a fun term if
this if it was a fun term I would be
okay with using it but it's not a fun
damn no yeah
it's the same thing I'm just a fan of
being honest and like Simpsons hoes are
hoes I'm not gonna change the lights
what I've noticed about women is that
the second they wanna
this another woman so in your own world
forget men for a second when another
woman wants to degrade another woman
what's the first thing they call her a
flag you're a hoe you're a slag you're
this you're that because they know
within their own group that is not the
category you're not going to get
offended like if someone calls me a
[__] or ignorant or something yeah cool
but if someone calls me a slag I'll say
and I'll be like get your facts straight
I do yeah
if you slept with more than one person
someone can say if you're slack so
you're saying I do think that it does
just depend on the person like I have
friends that like they're 19 their body
count is like over 100 yeah 100 yeah and
they're proud hoes like they literally
call their cell phone they call
themselves a slug they call themselves
what I said about the lack of like it's
just yeah
like what she was saying though I do
think some of my friends are like they
have trauma and they are damaged in a
way where
like they don't under that's the only
way they can seek validation is from
having sex with men it's very unhealthy
but it's very sad if they were if they
were like taught from a young I'm not
saying young young but like for if they
were maybe given the facts about things
like we spoke about like parabonding or
the the likelihood of divorce and the
likelihood of not finding someone do you
not think that they might actually okay
fair enough I [__] up in the past you
know what I mean statistically how many
people are growing up in one parent
families where they're not taught that
Dynamic of two parent households so
they're not taught
how to I'm just saying I'm just talking
generalization I'm not telling you
personally
um if like it takes that Dynamic so
you're an anomaly
situation I don't I just don't buy it
like when the girls are like oh I didn't
know I had no idea like if you didn't
know then your first reaction when a
girl pisses you off wouldn't be a color
or a [__] like I think innately we we
know I don't know if it comes from what
your parents do you know your parents
may not teach you these kind of it comes
from a lot of things I think the women
that are blur in the line of the word
hoes or the women are in between being a
hoe and being married and that space in
between there is a dangerous space for
women to be because the whole house like
real hoes like for real that know they
come in and smashing everybody in the
room they don't give a [__] like you
said they're proud hoes and they'll let
you know that they're a hoe and they'll
make it clear that we hoes and we out
here twerking and then the girls who are
married like you at the other end of the
spectrum I have a different perspective
the women in the middle that are single
trying to get out of the whole phase
trying to get out of the whole section
that's why they blur the line of like oh
I'm not a hoe I'm just dating on is just
my face this is my attention I think I
think it's a mating strategy though like
I think it's just like the top like
women fight for the top 20 percent of
men five percent of whatever it is ten
percent of men's attention and I think
like there's a group of women that know
they can't get their attention any other
way it's like either they're too far
gone so there's no way they're gonna
wipe them so you know what [__] I'll
just I'll just signal easy sex easy sex
easy sex and I'll get their attention
and that goes down that goes down to
insecurities that goes into self-esteem
I don't even think it's self-esteem I
think like the world will just let you
know real quick where you're at I do I
think
I think it's girls that are punching
that's true you know you might girls I
mean how many
how I mean Brittany Renner right
so yes yes I can um so Brittany Renner
um she's uh she's no she's a publico
um so basically she's just been with a
lot of like athletes rappers
entertainers like that's she's like
known for sleeping with a lot of people
in the industry so much so she wrote a
book yeah and like she didn't use any
other names but people kind of put
together who they were and then she also
like posted videos about like how to
catch a baby off of an NBA player like
yeah okay no you know what is sad about
like public figures like this like no
hey do what you want to do Etc but I
remember literally being in secondary
school like 15 14 years old and like my
friends would get up her videos on
Instagram and they'd be like oh see so
like it is fine that my body can't exist
and it is fine that I've had sex with
this many people like I don't care I
don't but sex is being so devalued in
today's society Society sorry but yeah
like I don't think it should be praised
to be a hoe I think yeah if you want to
be sexually free be sexually free you're
gonna find someone who doesn't care that
you're sexually free or they have a
sexually free past like just like we
were saying you accept people for their
flaws it's gonna get into some people
would but you're right there's a simple
I do think I do think public figures
like that is quite a negative impact on
your modeling that's that's simple it's
not going to be the guy you want though
to jump in because what you're saying
they're like
about the way that Brittany renner's put
out and no one really talks about what
comes after I think that kind of goes
back to what it was saying before where
the consequences of that behavior needs
to be discussed from those girls that
are doing that yeah he's about to say
that yeah it's like it's fine I think
you know whatever your lifestyle fair
enough but I think just getting around
the real life consequences of things is
that I think it's the real issue of like
listen if you want to do your you know
your your promiscuous phase or whatever
fine but let me just tell you what
happens to people who do that in the
wrong way and let's not like dance
around that but I'm not gonna be like oh
you slept with too many people you're
not good enough for this no but that is
the question
that is the consequences I just think
[__] yeah I just think I think no one's
really shouting but okay but I just
think I just think shame
um like it changes your behavior the
same way like when I was at work and
those guys being like yeah like I would
not touch a girl over too they didn't
know like because I I carry weight well
because I'm tall and so I don't think
they knew how much anyways but
um it's like hearing that like brutal
honest truth made me change my behavior
and I just think it's the same thing to
an extent but as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible